it was an unprecedented threat to
Vladimir Putin's leadership
the longtime Ally turned Nemesis of the
Russian president ordered his forces out
of russian-occupied Ukraine across the
border and on the road to Moscow but in
a dramatic about turn stopped just 200
kilometers short of the capital
in an audio message the mercenary group
leader announced his retreat
they wanted to disband the Wagner
military company we embarked on a March
of Justice on June 23rd in 24 hours we
got to within 200 kilometers of Moscow
in this time we did not spill a single
drop of our Fighters blood now the
moment has come when blood could be
spilled understanding the responsibility
that Russian blood will be spilled on
one side we are turning our columns
around and going back to field camps as
planned
it was a day of turmoil and confusion
platforms crowded with people at rostov
ondon train station as civilians rushed
to leave the city
as they fled others arrived Chechen
fighters on armored vehicles it's
unclear where they came from but they
vowed to crush the Mutiny by the Wagner
Mercenaries
the Chechen leader ramzan khadirov said
his men would do everything to preserve
the unity of Russia
Wagner's forces seized control of the
kremlin's military headquarters in
rostov online early on Saturday saying
they shot down a Russian military
helicopter
and social media has shown the Wagner
mercenaries on the streets of rostov
some of them even finding the time to
order fast food
they reached the region of Le piesk 400
kilometers from Moscow
but they faced resistance a Wagner
military Convoy heading north towards
Moscow came under Fire outside the city
of oronesh
in a TV address Russia's president said
punishment for what he called Wagner's
stab in the back was inevitable
we will protect our people and our
statehood from any threats including
internal betrayal and what we are facing
is betrayal exorbitant Ambitions and
personal interests led to treason
Russia's defense Ministry appealed to
Wagner fighters to abandon pregojin
saying they'd been tricked into what was
described as their Leader's criminal
adventure and participation in an armed
Rebellion tension between Wagner and the
kremlin's Armed Forces escalated during
the Battle of bakmut where the
mercenaries played a crucial role in the
drawn-out fight to capture the city
police raided Wagner's headquarters in
Saint Petersburg after an investigation
into brigos and was launched
for now on uneasy truce prevails but
even with this de-escalation the crisis
in Russia may be far from over
Al Jazeera
Daniel Hawkins has more from Moscow
well without a doubt this has been the
most significant and dramatic 24 hours
in Russia's modern political history
over the last three decades and it ended
as quickly and unexpectedly as it began
Evgeni pregozian and his Wagner PMC
seizing the southern Russian city of
rostov before taking just 24 hours to
march to within Striking Distance of
Moscow the negotiations that brought
this to an end that took place behind
closed doors and involved mediation from
Belarusian President Alexander
lukashenko the charges against the
beginning progression of our Mutiny will
be dropped he will be going to Belarus
into effective Exile the guarantor of
that according to the Kremlin Dmitry
peskov will be the Russian President
Vladimir Putin and his word as for the
Wagner Fighters those who did not
participate in this Mutiny they'll get
the chance according to the Kremlin to
sign contracts with the Russian Ministry
of Defense no negotiations were held
according to the Kremlin about any
replacement of the Russian top brass the
Russian high command one of the key
reasons that you're getting precaution
used to justify his so-called March of
Justice on Moscow a big sense of relief
here in the Russian Capital tonight as
Czech posts uh checkpoints are removed
armored vehicles and camouflage trucks
are taken off the streets and Monday
remains a public holiday and
nevertheless though more questions than
answers remain how exactly was this
armed Mutiny which has been labeled by
the Kremlin allowed to get so out of
hand so quickly where does this leave
Russian President Vladimir Putin and his
relationship with uh evgeny pragos and
PMC Wagner and what place will Russia's
most notorious and effective fighting
force now occupy within the Russian
military what effect will this have on
the conflict in Ukraine many of these
questions will have to be answered in
the coming days and weeks